so I want to talk about abstinence
before marriage and let me just say that
this is the you know this is not this is
not a religious conversation I'm not
going to make a moral argument non
religious people you know they like to
dismiss these kinds of these kinds of
discussions and because they say well
this is just religious it's it's
fundamentalist but I think that's kind
of it's kind of funny in a way it's kind
of ironic because these those same
non-religious people will also insist
that you do not need to be religious in
order to act with wisdom and prudence
and you know that's religious people
don't have a monopoly on that they'll
say well saving sex for marriage is
without question the wisest and most
prudent path I don't think any rational
person would deny that or can deny it
convincingly yet it is a wise and
prudent path that we are told is only
open to the religious I disagree with
that I guess I have a higher opinion I
guess of non-religious people that
non-religious people have of themselves
because I don't you know I don't see it
that way yeah it's true that religious
people generally believe in saving sex
for marriage I mean they believe you to
believe in it ideally how successful
they are and following through is a
different matter but it's so it's true
that they believe in it but it's not
true that you have to be religious in
order to see the wisdom in such a
strategy and I think if you wish to
address our most serious social problems
if you if you does if you desire the
benefits that could come from solving
these problems then then you should
advocate for abstinence before marriage
whether you're religious or not it
doesn't doesn't matter this is a
practical position now it may be a
spiritual position as well but that's
not you know that those two things don't
necessarily have to be linked all the
time like I also believe that some that
that murder is wrong and that is a I I
believe that spiritually you know I
believe it's wrong because 10
commandments says that it's wrong
because God says it's wrong but um but I
would still believe I would still
advocate outlawing homicide
even if the Ten Commandments didn't
exist and I would I would hold that
position for very obvious and practical
reasons right well I think the same is
true of saving sex for marriage and I'm
not comparing you know I'm not comparing
having sex before marriage to murder I'm
just saying that you know this is a this
you can make a very practical argument
in favor of it and I think anyone can
see the benefits of that path and anyone
can pursue that path regardless of
religion so now what I want to do is I
want to talk about the great societal
this great societal crises that could be
solved or at least greatly reduced by
keeping sex within the framework of a
monogamous and lifelong marriage so I'm
not gonna say anything you'll notice I'm
not gonna say anything about sin or
avoiding hell or anything like that it's
a different discussion from the one that
I'm gonna have right now I want to talk
about the temporal practical benefits of
this course and I think that you know
it's a very difficult thing when we look
at our cultural problems and we say how
are we gonna solve these problems but
then at the outset we rule out the most
effective solutions and it seems like
we're always doing that you know there's
like the the fundamental basic solution
that gets right to the root of the
problem but we rule that out we always
rule those solutions out because those
are lifestyle solutions those are
solutions that require sacrifice and
effort and hard work and so we rule
those how do we say no no not not that
but let's find something a little bit
further up on the tree right the weekend
with a you know let's find a solution
that's a little bit further up here
that's a little bit closer to the
surface a little bit more superficial
and therefore easier and I just don't
think I just don't think it works I
think we have to get to the root of it
and and and that's the only way to solve
some of these problems so but let me let
me go through a list here of a few of
the problems that could be solved or as
I said reduced anyway by savings
for marriage number one pretty obvious
fatherlessness okay there there are
basically three ways that a child can
end up in a fatherless home one is
divorce we'll talk about that in a
minute the other is death and obviously
we can't death can't be solved in any in
any way so that that's always gonna be
an issue but both of those categories
are in the minority in fact the number
of never married single mothers that is
single mothers who got pregnant out of
wedlock that number is greater than the
number of divorced and widowed single
mothers combined
okay so fatherlessness and all of the
terrible consequences that come with it
Prison drug abuse you know dropping out
of school all the mental health problems
you know all of these things that that
many times stem from fatherless all that
could be cut in half through abstinence
number two divorce so divorce itself you
know that's another way that a kid will
end up in a single-parent home and
divorce itself if we save saving sex for
marriage as a society that could greatly
reduce divorce studies have consistently
shown that marriages between people who
have never had sex with anyone else
virgin marriages we call them those are
less likely to lead to divorce than
marriages between previously sexually
active people
even marriages between people who were
previously sexually active only with
each other
so cohabitate you know people who
cohabitate shack up together before
getting married those arrangements are
more likely to lead to divorce than
couples who you know wraps it before
marriage and didn't live together before
marriage three poverty so now we can tie
together the first two items on the list
simple fact of the matter is the
statistics are pretty clear on this
children are four times as likely to be
impoverished if they live in
single-parent homes the statistics are
there are only eight percent of children
in married households are poor while
over 40 percent of children in
single-parent households usually single
mother households are poor that's an
incredible that is a incredible
statistic yet almost half of the kids in
single-parent homes are are poor well
you have a very tiny minority in married
households who are poor III think maybe
maybe that's something we should look at
and considering that most of those
children were born to unwed mothers the
connection between poverty and sex
before marriage I think should be pretty
evident number four STDs
we are currently experiencing an STD
epidemic in our country sexually
transmitted diseases are at record highs
across the country there are more
reported cases of chlamydia more cases
of gonorrhea more cases of syphilis
syphilis than ever before and here again
obviously you save sex for marriage you
don't have to worry about this to two
people who have sex who's safe sex for
marriage and then keep sex within
marriage they don't have to worry about
this problem at all
they could just take and laugh it off as
far as they're concerned don't have to
worry about it
so it's a wonderful thing no well you're
when you're in a company when you're in
a committed marriage and you're in a
faithful marriage so it's a wonderful
thing you don't the word it's a have you
no fear not not a problem not an issue
right number five abortion according to
the Guttmacher Institute which is a
pro-abortion Institute only fourteen
percent of the women who procured an
abortion last year were married that
means that the abortion rate could be
cut by eighty six percent if sex were
saved for marriage and then number six
sexual assault I think could be greatly
reduced by saving sex for marriage now
obviously you know getting married isn't
gonna protect a woman absolutely from
getting raped
nobody would claim that but um I think
the strategy would reduce the problem in
places like college you know you know on
a college campus and in other
environments where assaults often occur
within the context of a booze-fueled
hookup culture so a woman can
significantly not completely but
significantly insulate herself from from
that risk by withdrawing herself from
that scene entirely
and if the hook-up culture were
abolished you know if it didn't exist
anymore on college campuses then the
problem of sexual assault on college
campuses would I mean it would all but
disappear
now
I know that their response oh so what's
the response to everything that I mean I
think there's a pretty clear argument
pretty pretty pretty logical right
there's there's there's no denying that
that these problems could be could be
very significantly addressed by saving
sex for marriage what's the argument
against it then well people will say
we'll say you know you could solve most
of these problems with with safe sex
right just just use contraception you
know it gets rid of most of these
problems but here's the thing and then
in the corollary to that is is well you
know we so we have to make contraception
birth control we have to make it more
available to people so that that will
cut down on these issues but here's
here's the thing about that
contraception is already readily
available everywhere you know anyone can
obtain some form of birth control for
low cost or no cost so the idea that we
need better access to birth control is
just it's idiotic anyone can go to any
gas station any convenience store any
drugstore any Walmart any target any
grocery store and get contraception for
very cheap I mean you can get it for
free in many medical clinics how much
more accessible can it possibly be how
much more accessible do you need it to
be do we need the government to start
doing air drops literally dumping vats
of condoms from the from the helicopters
like do they do we need to send out the
the the National Guard to cities across
the merica cry across America in
helicopters with vats of condom just
condoms just dropping them sprinkling
them across the ground like a morning
dew drop so that when you walk out of
your house in the morning it's just it's
it's littered with birth control pills
and condoms would that be accessible
enough no I'm sure we even be told then
even that's not accessible enough it's
not enough access people are gonna say
you know what I needed someone from the
government to walk into my house every
morning and place birth control into my
hand that's the out for free that's the
only way it'll be accessible I mean it's
just it
it's ridiculous it is this stuff is
extremely accessible people talk about
birth control
you know it's like it's like the the
feminists who say that they need free
birth control or they need birth control
to be covered by their health insurance
for free or whatever they talk about
birth control as if you need $6,000 and
some kind of certification some sort of
license to buy a condom
you don't it's ridiculous this stuff is
super available and super cheap yet STD
rates are skyrocketing there are
historic highs fatherlessness is a huge
problem out of weather out of wedlock
births is a huge problem abortion is a
huge problem and these problems are all
worse now than they were 50 years ago
when birth control really was hard to
come by how do you explain that I mean
we should see if if if access to birth
control is gonna solve these problems
considering birth control has become
much more accessible over the years we
should be able to look at a chart of
these other problems like STDs out of
wedlock births etc and we should you
know while birth control is doing this
the problem should be doing that right
that's what we should see like if
there's an actual but that's not what we
see in fact with a lot of these problems
it's more like this hmm
you know that that's something I mean
it's that's interesting isn't it maybe
maybe there's no such thing as safe sex
outside of the bonds of a committed
marriage
you know or do we need another 50 years
of evidence before we come to that
conclusion do we need another 50 years
of shoving birth control down everyone's
throat and then seeing these problems
not only get worse we need another thing
that we need like how much how much more
time do we need before we could start
drawing some obvious conclusions maybe
you know maybe safely having sex with a
stranger that you met at a party is
about as possible as safely driving
drunk you know yeah you can mitigate
some of the risk to some extent by
wearing a seatbelt even if you're
driving drunk if you're getting if you
get behind the wheel of a car completely
plastered you might say it's it's safer
if you put a seatbelt on just as you can
mitigate some of the risk to some extent
by wearing a condom but the act itself
in both cases is fundamentally reckless
and dangerous and so really the only
safe course of action is to just not do
it
think about it we're saying to 16-year
olds like he got six he got you know
whatever sophomore juniors in high
school and we're saying hey if you're
gonna do this thing that could directly
result in pregnancy and life-altering
diseases do it safely and for us safe
means taking a drug or using a device
that will hopefully hopefully insulate
you maybe from some of the effects of
the act maybe again we should consider
this there is no safe sex
aside from sex with your spouse there's
no substitute for self-control
discipline fidelity there's no good
argument against self-control discipline
and fidelity other than the fact that
those things require effort but that's
not an argument that's just a complaint
let me mention one other thing
people will say that that abstinence
before marriage is is unrealistic and
you know first of all I could just as
well say that safe sex is unrealistic
because obviously a lot of people just
aren't willing to take those precautions
I mean you can talk about safe sex all
you want pretty clearly well many people
are just not they're not going to do it
so can't I make the same argument and
say that and say that the safe sex thing
is unrealistic
and and I could and I also I think it's
relevant here to point out that that
that just because a solution is
challenging doesn't mean that it's wrong
in fact the fact that it's challenging
is evidence that it's right because
there are no easy solutions for
difficult problems if life has taught us
anything it's that you cannot solve
difficult problems easily
if the solution is easy that's a good
indication that it's not a real solution
so when someone says I'm gonna solve
your obesity with a pill that sounds
great if someone says you know sit on
the couch eat whatever you want make no
changes here's a pill I'll solve your
obesity that's a pretty good indicator
that that's what we call too good to be
true if a person's solution for obesity
does not include diet and exercise then
their solution may be fun but it's not a
good solution and I think that principle
holds just pretty much with every big
problem you can think of so so there's
that but I I will admit that as things
are currently set up in society
abstinence before marriage as things are
currently set up without with our
society the way it is now abstinence
before marriage is an extremely
difficult proposition difficult because
humans you know the way that we work is
that we develop intense sexual desires
at the time of puberty which is around
13 or so but the average age of marriage
for men is almost 30 and for women it's
almost 28 so so so to be abstinent
before marriage requires according to
the average trajectory it requires 15
years of celibacy and those 15 years
happen to be the 15 years when the
desire for sex is the strongest and we
also happen to live in a society where
sex is being pushed in front of your
face constantly every day so it is
indeed quite a quite a big thing to ask
of somebody you know to expect a guy to
go through 15 years feeling the intense
desire for physical companionship with
will with women and and and in the midst
of a sex crazed culture and yet to
remain celibate the whole time you know
that is a that that's a that's a big
thing to to ask of somebody and most
people aren't able to do that aren't you
know willing to do it so so so they
become sexually active years and years
before marriage is even on the table
it's not just that it become sexually
active before marriage they become
sexually active before marriages even is
even you know a possibility and then we
have all these problems that I mentioned
before
so then what's the solution well here's
one
get married earlier you know this idea
of waiting forever to get married is
very new it's a very Western this idea
that marriage should be kind of the the
capstone of young adulthood
again very new very Western it's not the
way it used to be marriage was the
foundation the cornerstone of young
adulthood like he got married right at
the beginning of young adulthood and and
it was it was the kind of first step in
the door of adulthood and then from
there you did everything else that
that's how it used to be and now we've
taken it and we put it at the very at
the end this is not how our ancestors
handled it even just in the 1960s the
average age of marriage for women was 20
for men it was 21 or 22 and this also
meant you know that makes a lot more
sense biologically as well because a
woman's a woman's most fertile angel age
range is 20 to 24 and then her fertility
declines dramatically in her 30s but now
we wait until our 30s to get married
then ever everyone's wondering then why
they can't get pregnant and now while
you know everyone's going to fertility
clinics and everything say like what's
going on nobody can get pregnant well
it's because everyone is spending their
most fertile periods having sex with
strangers and then when they finally
settle in with a spouse and they say
let's start a family
they can't anymore I mean just this
whole strategy it makes no sense it
doesn't work it's dysfunctional on every
level
it's just the way that we approach sex
and relationships and marriage it's
dysfunctional it's not working it's it's
bad it's just there's no it's not
working look at the evidence so even
though I know you know this isn't gonna
happen I think if we're really talking
about real solutions what we would start
advocating for we have to care for two
things absent is before marriage and
earlier marriage right that's what we
that's what we would at if we if we're
really serious about
because here's here's the important
point there is no solution to these
problems that does not include a drastic
lifestyle change
and a drastic cultural change
there there is no solution that will
alleviate us of the you know from the
need to to make those kinds of changes
you
telling everyone to use contraception
that's not a cultural change it's not a
lifestyle change and so that's why it's
not working because our these problems
stemmed from not you know not just
obviously physically they begin with the
sexual act but but at a deeper level
they stem from certain lifestyle choices
that we make now and cultural attitudes
that we have about marriage sex
relationships
to change those attitudes and those
those lifestyles
and again if we're not willing to do
that if we're ruling that out as a
possibility then we're just not going to
solve any of these problems and we might
as well stop talking about it
and we might as well just accept that I
mean you could talk about safe sex all
you want but people are gonna use a
condom they're not gonna use a condom
whatever they can do whatever they want
to do and I mean one way or another look
one one way or another if we are
if we are just accepting that people are
going to have sex for 15 years before
they ever get married
you know then we're just accepting the
fact that all these problems are going
to are going to be very common
so let's talk about real solutions
that's my that's my proposal and you
know I know nobody's gonna take me up on
it but I thought it throw it out there
anyway thanks for watching nobody thanks
for listening and have a great weekend
Godspeed